i was out in phoenix out there the rally
in the valley people are fired up out
there about their hoops team
and they're playing hoops out there they
got a lot of brothers out in the desert
and i think one white
and they hooping the hell out of the
damn ball out there
i stayed at a like this kind of sober
living place while i was there and it
was
they had a like one night they had
somebody got in a motorcycle accident
and they came to the door like the
police came
and uh and i felt kind of bad because
the day before we were all going to the
gym
if you've never been to a sober living
sometimes when you're there everybody
you get in a van and you all go
somewhere together
because you just that's who you are
you know it's like uh it's like a
daycare but for adults
that
are
that would sometimes rather probably
have drugs than lunch
so if you're like lunchtime and somebody
shot up
it's like that sort of camaraderie that
sort of club
style style and so um
so anyway we got there i got there and
uh because i went to this therapy thing
for a week to this like kind of
intensive therapy place because you know
me bro
i got uh i either have something
i either got you know i'm always put
pressing the gas on that something's
wrong with me pedal
you know
so i'm in that freaking hov lane bro
something's wrong with everybody you
know what i'm saying i'm bringing it's
all aboard
so anyway i'm at this sober living dude
they got um oh god
they had it's like you know it's regular
people if you ever been to one it's a
real hodgepodge of
america it's kind of like a lost and
found
but a couple more lost
it's lost heavy and so i'm there you
know i roll up and
uh they got a do there's one guy 65-ish
you know
and whenever you ask him anything hey
man what's going on he's like just being
this
this is just staying sober this thing is
over
what you're doing today is getting the
visa over this he would put his hands up
like it was like the police were
like every time you were like hey man is
there any milk out of just
being sober you know not from around
here like
everything was like i remember like one
time i
just asked him a question you know i was
like hey what's the weather like and he
handed me his license and registration
so you know there's some real you know
america's top miscreants you know it's a
real it's
it's regular folks man you know and
i could have stayed in a hotel or motel
or
um hell i could have been homeless if i
wanted to but i chose to be
here there where i was
so yeah it was wild they had us uh uh
hasidic jewish dude i don't know if you
ever even
seen this this guy
had on like
all these coats he had like uh
he looked like he looked like
like biggie smalls
but like biggie smallsburg kind of
like he had on like all he had on like a
a jacket it was so thick it was a
hundred and
probably 11 degrees out there you know
you could feel a [ __ ]
i mean it feel i felt like there was a
dragon outside
that's the levels of
air heat
because the air will hold heat the air
is just really just a briefcase for damn
heat or cold
you know that's mother nature's
briefcase man
the air because that's where she puts
all of her [ __ ]
you know but anyway so this fella man he
was as
i mean he was you know this little
gimbal spanner was about as damn jewish
as you could get he had on
he he had on the hat the hat had on a
hat
he had like he yeah he uh
and if you haven't seen hasidic jewish
person you got to look it up
because i'd never seen it i'd seen it
maybe you know in the distance
i'd seen like one of these hj's at a
distance but i'd never seen up close
you know and this fella he had on the
head he had on the dr
the drapes the curtains he had on the
door he had on nine
it was he had on 19 layers
of clothing he had socks his socks were
wearing brassieres like
he had i can't even imagine
he was wearing about four loads of
laundry
and he shows up and he's like hi and it
was uh it was
119 degrees and if you don't know
anything about hasidic culture
they can't drive on
uh the sabbath on like from friday
sundown i think until saturday sundown
so these fellas these bad boys and girls
they gotta walk
so this dude had basically
i mean he'd probably come from mars
you could hear his like
his shoe or it was just whatever it was
just like
he's like hi it's hot
like yeah it's hot man and so every you
know
people's there but you know it's a damn
sober living some do you know
one guy in the kitchen i'm like oh man
we're having dinner like this salad is
so good and he's like yeah
it's really good i was dead for 30
minutes two weeks ago so
everything's good all right damn okay
bro
okay man down so you really
you really tasting this ranch you really
tasting
this fat free ranch today and you you
know
you're really enjoying and appreciating
and gratitude in that uh
that ranch um
but this is so uh
what it was cool they had like a little
um
place to swim in the back and it was so
hot the water you got in the water it
was like being in a um
it was like hiding in somebody's mouth
say you would
say you were playing hide and go secret
people
and you somebody was uh had a heat
stroke
a real big person big big so
probably 11 feet tall maybe 600 pounds
and you hid in their mouth
during uh hide and go seek and you hid
in their mouth
that would be what the heat was like
that hot you know
somebody who had a heat stroke and was
also
um they were late
there was also somebody was pouring heat
on them
somebody had two bags of damn heat and
we're just filling them [ __ ] up with
it warming them
um so that was wild
uh and then so the crazy thing is so
we're all going to the gym one day and
this one fella had gotten a new
motorbike
and he's kind of coasting through the
red lights and just living life you know
and uh and you know and i respect no
helmets because
the lord is looking for some people
and everybody wants to be alive and
everything and
and i get it but we don't
know what it's like when you die
i mean it must here's the thing it's so
good i bet it's so good
nobody's coming back from it
there was a couple ghosts i think that
came back allegedly from the
1700s or whatever but then [ __ ]
apparently they fixed heaven up because
nobody's been coming back
name the last ghost you even heard about
you know ray charles maybe or somebody i
don't even know who
i mean he's not a ghost i mean he's
blind but that's that's not a ghost
a ghost is if you can't see them so he's
like a reverse ghost
you know but um
but anyway so we're out there we're crew
we're going to the gym in the
van you know if you do sober living just
you know you that dirty grade school
class
you know you're just that you know
you're a little more lost than fam
and so we rolling out and this other
fellow got a motorcycle
and so he's zipping and zoo daddy and
doing this and doing that and stunting
let my daddy
and i tell the other guys in the van i
said hey uh
it's cr i said i used to talk about
organ donation
because my sister make sure my head is
alright
my sister got an organ when i was a
child and she got uh
liver she got liver
and uh which i wouldn't have got i would
have got two hearts
you know you're like hey what are you
doing i'm like hey man throw another
freaking
throw another pump in here you know what
i'm saying boy i'll be running hot dude
all the dance moves you could do would
you if he was double hearted
uh but but so anyway the um
the uh so so anyway this guy's skirting
and stuff and go we're all headed to the
gym
this guy's skirting around on this on
his bike
and uh and i say man guys you know what
i said he's he's really
reckless you know he's a reckless man
out here
and i said a lot of organ donors
the next day i come home and uh
the the fella the police had shown up
and the fella had been in a accident
in a coma or comma
you know they're both pauses
and and we're like like
why i'm like am i predicting the future
right now
so it was just you know and i hope he's
in
i i you know i need to check and see if
he's i'm gonna text somebody right now
see if they got still comb it up
yeah i'm gonna see if he's okay uh so
so anyway i don't they had a candlelight
vigil like on the third night
the full uh the fifth night uh
it was cool we got to sit in there and
watch like some basketball games
together
and hockey uh the canadians
you know those frogs bro i don't know if
anybody
follows hockey but it'd be awesome to
cheer for the canadians
if everybody else in canada didn't hate
them
that's the weird thing montreal is like
kind of that french bad boy
you know it's like everybody else is in
a big fight and then you got some dude
over there smoking a cigarette and
sucking on the freaking
on the on the dirty side of a crepe you
know what i'm saying that back hole baby
that back jaw
you know somebody freaking uh you know
sneaking into a crepe all nasty from the
back dude
eat a crepe from the front you creep
and crepe and creep is just one letter
different bro
so if you want nasty eggs dog get em
french you
feel me get em french
praise god man and then the last day i'm
there the uh hasidic guy shows up
hello this dude had i mean i don't think
he'd ever seen reg
non uh sids you know non
um hasidic people because it's a real
tight cult it's basically like
they're like the uh
they're kind of like the financial
native americans kind of you know
they're real
or i don't they're like man they're real
religious
like way religious
like i was telling my friend josh wolfe
about it and he said that hasidic people
don't even consider him jewish they're
like
you got to be in there
but that guy they gave him a chapstick
somebody and he never used it
so for the next like 14 hours this dude
is over there just going hard bro
just going hard on some pink lemonade
baby
he had that pink lemonade chaps taking
everything about every nine seconds
you'd look over and he'd be like
[Music]
dude that dude i think he by the time i
left and he had chapstick his whole
face he had chapstick his he just
couldn't stop
man you know and thankfully we're all
you know everybody that's in the places
had some issues with addiction so at
least he's in the right place now
but and also at least if the sun hits
him now out there he'll have a little
bit of uh
of a block on him you know
because that's
hello dude it was anyway
it was needless to say it was a wild
week
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one